this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host
number one best-selling author
and
host of the ken coleman show ramsey
personality ken coleman is my co-host
today
as we talk about your life and your
money and your career now guess what you
know where your money comes from
your money comes from your career
and so this idea of uh you want to
change your budget you can also change
the amount of money that goes in the top
line of the budget
and uh it changes your budget so we're
always talking about around here ken the
uh
shovel and hole ratio if you're in a
sixty thousand dollar hole of debt how
big is your shovel to get out of that
that's your income yeah you have a
hundred and twenty thousand dollar
shovel or do you have a twenty thousand
dollar shovel it's gonna change how fast
you get out of that hole and so
sometimes changing the shovel getting a
bigger shovel yes sometimes it's extra
work sometimes it's a new career but
almost every debt-free scream we ask
them for a range of their income and it
has gone up i've never heard one where
it didn't so i'm here today of course
we're gonna answer your life and money
questions we're gonna talk about that
bigger shovel do you need to switch to
get a bigger shovel or do you need to
get promoted to get a bigger shovel we
could simplify it to those two things
it's that so we want to help you do it
we've got people we're talking about
both in this world today oh boy so jobs
careers money
inextricably intertwined oh yes and uh
we're here to help you with all of that
here on the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
starting this hour in greensboro north
carolina austin is with us hey austin
how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
uh so i'm about three thousand dollars
in debt um i'm 18 years old
um but i but i bought my car for about
five thousand dollars and i put two down
on it
and i was wondering um
i have a committed relationship i've
been in for about a year and seven
months now and i was wondering uh
how could i get a second job to help me
pay for that debt but still maintain a
relationship with my girlfriend and i
plan on starting college in the spring
so i was just wondering the best way to
tackle that well how much time are you
spending with this girlfriend you 18
year old young man you how many hours a
week are you spending with her
uh we i spend about probably like five
to six hours a day or something like
just when i get home from work in the
evenings but you know she's one of those
girls that go to bed real early like at
eight or nine o'clock so i feel like by
the time i look at oh she's already
gonna sleep off of me well first of all
austin let me just tell you something
you are a fantastic young man i think
you got a bright future all right this
is super practical bro you're 18. i'm
going to speak to you like the 47 year
old that i am i'm going to be a dad for
a moment uh you're 18. i love that you
want to pay the car off it's absolutely
the thing that you need to make your
number one priority so get the second
job any way you can do you know how many
people whether it's food delivery or
right now there are restaurants that'll
pay you 15 an hour starting pay to wait
tables in a chain restaurant i'd go and
i'd carve out three or four nights a
week your girlfriend's gonna be fine and
go make the extra money pay the debt off
and keep saving it up you guys aren't
married you're 18 go work the extra job
and pay off the car five hours a month
it's five hours a day it's just a little
too much austin
[Laughter]
i mean i love his commitment to the
young lady i think he's gonna be a great
husband but dude you're not married pay
the car
get get yeah just take the just split
split down the middle you can say four
nights a week i'm
you know i'll be over at the restaurant
come see me she could sit in the booth
and i don't want you to i don't want you
to work but half a day 12 hours okay and
so
yeah but i appreciate the question but
yes pay the car off fast we're like a
couple old men muppets here we are
grumpy on that one that's yeah that's
true all right ken is in plattsburgh new
york hey ken what's up
candidate hey guys thanks for taking my
call there you are hey what's up how can
i help
hey so my wife and i work with ellen
tents we're on baby step two and uh i
recently used the proximity principle to
move into my sweet spot of my company
nice start a new role
um but i'm underpaid and i'm looking for
tips i start next month i'm looking for
tips on how to
you just started when you're underpaid
and you moved up no i've been with i've
been with the companies for four years
i'm starting a new role i know but i
mean you started a new role that's
underpaid
correct that's kind of where i'm about
i'm about to okay and why are you
underpaid in the new role let's step
back real quick question do you feel you
were underpaid in the previous role
yes
okay i was recently promoted in the
previous role all right but
okay and so now you're in another role
and you feel you're underpaid for that
role as well so something there's a
disconnect what's the evidence that you
have i'm not doubting you i just need to
understand how you're coming to the
conclusion that i just said yes to a
promotion and i feel i'm underpaid
what's the evidence
research so i look at the data from the
bureau of labor statistics on what that
rule is typically paid what the company
is reporting they pay for that rule that
range okay it's definitely on the lower
end okay and okay so you're on the lower
end of the range are you salary or
hourly
salary okay uh what would be how much
more money would have made you feel good
you wouldn't be calling us today how
much more real number
uh 20 000 more 20 000 more and yet you
said yes to this so i i honestly i'm
trying to dive in here how can we help
you today when you just said yes to a
job that going into it you've got a bad
taste in your mouth because you think
you should be making 20 000
more why would you say yes to that
because i was
recently promoted and that's what they
offered
i understand
right but you didn't answer my question
because you've got some bad psychology
would you agree with me
yes you don't feel good about this
so how can we help you what's your
question specifically because i feel
like you've already said yes so here's
what your options are as i see because
i'm excited about the opportunity so i'm
i'm trying to demonstrate that i'm worth
more okay so totally what's making me
want okay
so you took it as a a perspective i'm
gonna take it i feel like i should make
more but i'm gonna take it because i see
the opportunity to make more have they
made that clear to you that there are
some things you can do and and a
promotion and you see a track where
you're gonna make more money in the near
future
yes i do
all right then so then you got and
you're not underpaid then you're not
underpaid you said i'm gonna take a
chance on myself and bet on myself so
now you got to go all in
yeah you just got to go do the things
they said to do in order to get the more
pay get the extra pay
yeah that's the thing so you know you
didn't you're
you're temporarily underpaid but that's
a whole different thing than saying i'm
underpaid and because you're not
underpaid you're not and that's the
number one thing the number one homework
assignment i'm going to give you is you
got to change your mindset
the way you said it to us is completely
wrong we had to dig into it here's the
new change i just took an opportunity
that i believe is going to pay off for
me and so i'm going to own it so here's
what you got to do you better be super
clear on what a win looks like if you
don't know now you better sit down with
your leader day one and go how do we say
that this is a win how do we measure
against that and then you better go do
that you better have an attitude for the
future or else it's not going to play
out you're going to be focused on how
little money you're making as opposed to
how much you could make yeah i took a
pay cut and or i took a job making less
than maybe i should so that i have an
opportunity is different it's a
different attitude than i'm underpaid
i'm underpaid sounds ungrateful
when you just accepted the job
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hey listen our last live show of the
year every year is right before
christmas we run best dubs between
christmas and new year's for those of
you who don't know and our last live
show is always our giving show and we
want to highlight generosity so if
you've been the recipient of some
generosity or maybe you were generous
and you had a
cool experience with generosity on
either side of the equation
we want you to tell your story on that
show we have three hours of a giving
show on december the 22nd
so let us know if you're out there and
would love to and would participate in
that i want to hear your stories and
inspire other people to generosity
because it is the most fun you have with
money
so how do we get in touch with you you
go to ramseysolutions.com
ask
put giving in the subject line go to
ramseysolutions.com
ask and put giving in your subject line
and uh kelly and the team will get in
touch with you we'll put you into
that first deal now we all know the
story of the tortoise and the hair and
it's of course one of our favorites
around here slow and steady always wins
the race but we often overlook the
reason for the hare's downfall he didn't
lose because he was slow
he lost because he took a nap
and he didn't stay on task
he chose to put off what he knew he
should do in favor of what he wanted to
do
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
so if you're an adult if you're a
tortoise out there we know how hard it
is to keep pushing fighting and hacking
away at your debt especially when you
see
all the hairs around you quitting their
jobs deferring their student loans
financing fancy vacations wouldn't it be
great to get a boost this time of year
well that's what the ramsey christmas
cash giveaway is all about this year
we're giving away up to five thousand
dollars and you can enter to win at
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway entering every day to increase
your chances of winning and for an extra
dose of motivation time for new year our
team's featuring a new deal every day
this week today
you can buy christy wright's new
devotional book living true 40 days to
get back to you it's on sale for 10
it's a great devotional this will make
the perfect gift for the women in your
life make 2022 your best wealth building
year yet shop our one day deal at our
online store at ramseysolutions.com
jackson's in salt lake city hey jackson
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave can you hear me yes sir
thanks for having me sure what's up
so
i have a little bit of a dilemma i made
more money than i thought i was going to
this year and i so i ended up maxing out
my roth 401k
in both my roth ira as well as my
wife's
roth ira
um but my income is looking like it's
going to be around 230 000 i had a
really good queue for them in sales
i'm wondering what i can do well your
401k is not affected by that but only
the two right individual roth iras uh
who have you got those iras with
uh so one is with uh well actually
they're both with fidelity okay just get
in touch with fidelity they can walk you
through it you've got to undo that
transaction because you can't go
straight into a roth making over 200k as
you have already discovered what you can
do though is go ahead and just set those
up to be an after tax
traditional
ira
and you can do that and then after the
first of the year you can roll them
to a roth
and that's after the first of the year
you said that's called the yeah but you
got to move them to an after tax first
move them to an after tax so you're not
getting penalties or any problems anyway
because you haven't paid in taxes
and you you know the the income is
taxable now and it wasn't
it was going to be taxable when it went
into the roth and it's still taxable so
it doesn't affect your taxable income
either way but move them into an after
tax and then you can ira and then you
can roll them into a roth from that
after january 1. this is the last year
you can do that that's called a backdoor
roth ira
biden administration in the latest round
of um
legislation did away with the back door
i'm surprised it lasted this long it's
been there for many many years and
everybody kept talking about closing the
back door the purpose was
uh you know there was it was a
workaround is what it was it was a legal
way of doing a roth when the didn't meet
the guidelines i do i've done an after
tax and rolled it over every year i've
done a back door roth every year and
sharon has too we'll do our last one
this year and then we'll just keep
smiling and move right along uh i have
to ask chances that that ever reopens no
never again no it should not have been
there it was an anomaly right in the law
the intent of the law was not to allow
high-income earners to do roth iras that
was the intent of the law
and so um unless somebody just came
along and said oh it's okay for you to
save money now
but that would be that would be a novel
thing to happen around congress or let's
let wealthy people actually get tax
benefits too oh no they're evil they
must be punished later i did it i
revealed that i'm a capitalist pig dude
yeah we knew that
marshall's in tulsa oklahoma hey
marshall what's up
hello dave how are you doing better than
i deserve how can we help
yes sir i called the previous show uh to
speak to ken pertaining to a job
question
the the long and the short was i was
laid off during cove ed
currently need to get out of debt and
hesitant to go back to my old industry
because i want to make more of an impact
and help people and then have the money
to be able to bless others
okay and so what do we know if there's
any
guidance there as far as
um i can go back and work for a you know
a corporation and make good money um but
i i wanna
i feel it really doesn't help a bunch of
people or or
make more of an impact than
either community or society okay so how
long how long have you been laid off are
you still laid off are you in another
position i am still still laid off how
long have you been laid off
um
since march of 20. i had started a a
couple of different ventures and and
haven't had success with them okay let's
talk about we need to first thing we
need to do is we need to get stable and
when we get stable then we can start
looking towards what do i want how are
you paying your bills yeah
um day trading
i know that's not a good one but um
you know breaking even or you know
making the the minimums there and then
uh real estate um uh
referrals and stuff how quickly could
you get back into your industry you
started off a call saying i could get
back in my industry how realistic is
that probably
two weeks okay that's your first move
let's go get a job
let's go get back in the industry i know
it is not that desired uh we'll get to
that in a second but you need to get
stable and stop playing with fire you
need to get some mojo back too you know
like let's get that shovel moving again
and then let's start to go okay where do
i really want to go do you understand
what i'm saying
yeah you're not going to this is this is
all emotional and mental right now you
know my concern is not helping you
discover what you want to do i mean i
can give you some tools i'm going to
give you some stuff to do some to do
some introspection and get some ideas
but you first need to understand that
you're making excuses for why you aren't
working by saying well it's just not
work that i love and i'm not picking on
you i'm just going to be really honest
with you it's a big giant excuse and i
love the fact that you called that you
want to discover work that matters
deeply to you but many times that's an
excuse dave to kind of go well i'm out
here and i'm floundering because i don't
want to go back here no we do what we
have to do
so that later we can do what we want to
do and i want him to get back in and get
hired and what i'd love to give him is
let's give him two things let's give him
a get clear career assessment 20 minute
assessment it's like me interviewing you
for 20 minutes and you're gonna get a
really good detailed report with a
purpose statement that'll point you to
many different jobs in the marketplace
the second thing is my new book the
best-selling from paycheck to purpose
it's the guide
up the mountain once you discover the
mountain so i want you to take those two
resources and dive into them you'll get
some ideas but he's got to get stable
first and stop making excuses for why
he's not moving forward
absolutely yeah you're not paying the
bills and that's led you to doing some
silly things that are going to get you
in serious trouble
so you're much better off to just
stabilize and go from a stable platform
than from
day trader
to failed idea to failed idea today
trader the failed idea it's a failed
idea that's not going to lead you into
anything except trouble
that's what that whole mess is and
that's um
oh that's scary that's scary i need to
get in a calm
situation
this
is the ramsay shot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at
825-5225
megan is in trinity florida hi megan how
are you
hey good dave how you doing better than
i deserve what's up
merry christmas i have a christmas
question for you okay so i'm we are baby
steppers four five and six we are bsms
we're about six months of shy of paying
off our house
i want to buy my husband a really nice
christmas gift what is that
what do we do well we want to get them
golf clubs like three thousand dollars
now okay
and so i'm wondering like what do we do
as far as transparency you know i don't
want him to know about it well don't
tell him aren't you going to have those
if you're going to buy a nice set of
golf clubs aren't they going to be
fitted
well probably but if i just buy like
this certificate to give him on
christmas day or something like that i
got an idea or just in general i gotta
dave and i both love golf so we'll tag
team this so dave's right he's gonna
want to be fitted these are really nice
clubs i i say get him a really nice golf
bag one of the stadium bags that'll
stand up on its own like tour level and
then you kind of put some kind of note
or whatever your creativity would be to
reveal why you've got given him an empty
golf bag he's going to be excited about
the bag potentially if you can get a
hold of his golf buddies and they can do
some research for you that's one way to
present
the uh golf clubs and that the fact that
he's going to be fitted yeah you don't
have to pre-pay for him yeah
okay can you give him a box of coffee
and give him a box of golf balls with an
envelope the whole thing getting my
entire outfit the bag i mean everything
i'm trying to get this guy more presents
right now what's going on
like how does he go about getting me
something and surprising me because i'm
the one that does all the finances
oh i have the answer to that too dave
because because
so which because stacy handles most of
the administrative stuff because if you
know me you know that that's a good
thing
and uh so uh every year when i get her
her big thing uh we have an agreement we
have a budget for our gifts anyway so
that's all been cashed out until we've
got that and so i said hey i need you to
stay out of the account for uh a day or
two because everything's planned out and
i just i don't want you to see it and
wait i handle it that way and she she
honors it
it's not that difficult
you guys trust each other yeah well you
guys trust each other you're enjoying
accounts you say hey stay out of the
account for a couple days
perfect
thanks
easy enough there it is boy i like those
calls i was getting this guy clubs a
golf bag shoes the whole nine yards i
kind of like that yeah
you're more about the outfit than the
actual golf yeah dave knows too much
about my golf game this is the fact i'm
the guy that shows up on the first tee
if you never play with me and you go oh
he's gonna be pretty good one swing
later you go oh it's about the outfit
this is true i have to i have to own it
would you like to hit a breakfast ball
oh casey's with us in milwaukee
wisconsin hi casey welcome to the ramsay
show
hello um
thanks for answering um i just had a
question so
i have a job interview today and
probably like 20 minutes or so oh and i
was just wondering um
when do i ask about like the salary and
the interview process so
i
know the supervis one of the supervisors
that's interviewing me and he told me
what the pay should be for the position
but when i looked online it said a
different pay than what he had told me
so i just wanted to figure out how to
navigate that yeah is this your first
interview
yes yeah do not ask about it in the
first interview if it's something
appropriate that they're going to bring
up in the first interview then you can
ask questions when you get to that stage
and in any kind of normal healthy
interview process there'll come a time
where they make you an offer at which
point you can ask any questions around
the offer but uh
if you know him well that would be the
one asterisk dave i it feels like
because he knows him and he and because
he's already mentioned it to you um you
could say maybe when the interview's
done go hey uh you mentioned this in our
in our last conversation and i was just
doing some research on the company
online i saw it was a different thing is
there is it what's the difference in
that and just kind of maybe because you
know him and if you feel the interview
went well uh i would think that's a
that's an asterisk for me on that one is
that what do you think about that what
was the pay you were told and what was
the pay online
um the pay he told me so it's it's
salary positions would be about 900 a
week and i think online it said like 750
800 i think it's at 800 on mine
it was about 100 difference a week
okay
all right it's 5 000 difference a year
it's worth knowing of the difference on
it um yeah but um but is that is that a
deal breaker either way
um i'm so i'm going to this job from a
job that pays more but this will give me
a lot more work-life balance so
i'd rather not take that much of a
decrease
okay so it is a deal breaker
yeah and so um yeah i think you bring it
up towards the end of the interview if
the interview is going well and you feel
like it's heading on you know
um yeah but if it's not going well that
just the fact that you're preoccupied
with the income might be enough to throw
you out
okay yeah if the first thing out of
somebody's mouth in an interview with me
is how much do you pay and what are the
benefits yeah i figure they're coming
here for what they can get rather than
what they can give yeah
and i want people that add value that
are not takers and so if the first thing
the first three minutes of the interview
all you want to talk about is how much
you're going to get paid
um that's a sign you're coming to
collect money not coming to add value
and um and that'll end the interview
process if it's with me i'll be kind
about it but i'm done
that's it so you do have a button that
you push and they don't know where the
chair drops to it's eject yeah it just
disappears
they drop into the golf bag and so there
it is there it is it comes back again
john's with us in sacramento hey john
welcome to the ramsey show
hello hey how you guys doing great man
what's up
so i i have a question i just started
listening to you about a month ago and i
just sold my house and got some cash i
just don't know how to navigate this
cash or where to put that towards
okay how much cash did you get
about 140. good for you gain debt other
than that
house oh no that good okay so what's
your plan with the 140 what are you
thinking you're going to do
um
as of right now i'm not looking for
looking to buy a house anytime soon uh
i i don't have no retirement or i have a
savings on my daughter for her school
okay so why are you not buying a house
anytime soon
uh i just felt like
i i just felt like i don't know where to
settle yet
you know what i mean i just don't want
to stay in california long term but my
wife is finishing up her nursing school
here so we don't really know where we
want to be yet cool when will she be
finished
uh she'll be finished next year in may
okay good
so you need to park it somewhere where
you can get get it sometime after may
right
correct now you can put it into a cd if
you want or you can put it into a low
risk
uh very calm mutual fund like a growth
and income stock mutual fund with one of
our smartvestor pros that would be okay
i mean there's a lot of places you can
park it and that's really what you're
wanting to do you do need to carve off a
portion of it and put it in a money
market and call that your rainy day fund
your emergency fund at three to six
months of expenses
and as far as your retirement goes and
your
kids college goes those should be coming
out of your monthly budget you ought to
be saving 15 percent of your household
income into retirement ongoing at this
stage of the game you have an emergency
fund in place which brings you and your
debt free which brings you to baby step
four 15 of your income going into
retirement kids college is baby step
five and paying off your house early
baby step six but this money is for the
next house purchase the vast majority of
it anyway
and it sounds like so i would just set
it in a cd for a year 18 months
and um
or you could sit with a smart investor
pro click at click smart vest ramsey
solutions dot com and that will help you
get started on your investing and you
can pick out some calm
mutual funds to park it in for 18 to 24
months before you buy uh be okay or you
could do a little both wouldn't hurt
that'd be another way to split it up and
and keep it going the big thing you
don't want to do is just leave it laying
around without it being labeled
something you want a label on it this is
future house money leave it alone this
is the emergency fund leave it alone
unless there's an emergency it's not a
bass boat fund
it's not i found a cool car fund
and it's not mama wants a new couch fund
this is your future house fun don't let
it get dribbled away
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personalities my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five five two two five casey's with
us from fort worth texas hi casey how
are you
hey dave hey ken how are y'all doing
today better than we deserve man what's
up
awesome so i'm 19 years old completely
debt-free um i'm trying to figure out
right now if i because i live at home i
have a 1 000 emergency fund say that but
i plan on going to college here in about
six years it's about all the money that
i make oh stop stop stop stop why are
you waiting six years to go to college
or six months six months oh i feel so
much that makes more sense
okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah so six months six months of
planning on going to college okay and uh
you know
it's my parents my parents have
extremely blessed me uh they've blessed
me with paying for college and they've
also blessed me with sending me through
flight school wow
so
yeah i've been extremely blessed in that
sense um but you know they kind of told
me they said you know you can either a
you can live at home with us and keep
going to college online about to
graduate with my associates from a
community college this semester
and then i'm going to go finish off a
degree in uh personal finance
yeah um next uh next year and so i'm
just trying to figure out if i should
start building up that emergency fund
more and just put investing off to the
side now because i've just about maxed
out my roth ira for this year yeah i'm
just trying to figure out what i should
do yeah okay you need you need a big
pile of cash to ensure that you're able
to finish your educational goals
whatever they are
and i know mom and dad are paying for
most of it um but to make sure that you
finish because you investing in you is a
better rate of return than you investing
in mutual funds and that's not a uh
a philosophical statement that's a
mathematical statement
your education will add more to your
income than the mutual funds would have
added to your in to your uh wealth
uh during that same period of time with
that same amount of money
okay yeah that makes sense and then
another little question that i had is
kind of like i was saying my parents
they they kind of want me to stay home
and just continue doing school online
they see me as kind of going up to
college
being a waste of my money when i could
keep investing it
um so i'm just trying to pick out your
guys's brain what you guys think might
be the best for me do you have the money
to pay cash to live on campus
uh i wouldn't i wouldn't be living on
campus up to living off campus but yes i
would how would you do that you told me
you had a thousand dollars
uh so i mean i work right now i work
full time i'm also in sight school and
stuff like that so it's uh
but by the time i plan on getting over
there i i plan on having a job with the
local airport as a flight instructor so
i should be making at minimum like 20
ish an hour i hope hopefully working
about 40 hours a week uh the question i
have is are you you planning to be a
pilot or are you planning to use that
personal finance degree professional i
need to be a pilot yeah yeah pilot is
the end goal for me so it sounds like to
me your mom and dad know that and
they'll go they're going look we'd
rather you you know finish up online and
uh because you're really going towards
the whole flight path anyway
and it sounds like you want the college
experience sounds like that's really
yeah there's no right or wrong here it's
what you want to do and you shouldn't
feel the pressure from mom and dad if
they're if they're going to pay for the
school
and you can pay for your living expenses
then i think you got to do what you want
to do and have that experience
all right
all right yeah
i think what
by moving out
um it's kind of you know it's it's
nothing like i love my family life you
know they've been great parents to me
they've left me and uh you know
unfathomably but it's just you know i've
been living here for almost 20 years now
what is gained
by moving out
um what is it what is it you're seeking
uh independence i guess mostly okay
that's fair that's a good answer yeah
it's what i was hoping you were going to
say yeah yeah
yeah and so and so um
i mean if you're working 40 out you're a
flight instructor at 19. wait a minute i
just drove by that for real
yeah
yeah well i'm not i'm not a flight
instructor yet i'm working on my
commercial license now um to where i can
eventually actually get hired and then i
plan on going to a two-week course to
where i can get my flight instructor
certificate and then i'll be able to
start teaching at that point because i'm
guessing you started flight school at 16
uh i started at i started at eight uh
i think like i started at 17 i started
like right towards like right a little
bit before my 18th birthday okay
um
so what does it cost to live out
in this apartment or whatever it is
um so i'm figuring at the very very high
end probably about a thousand dollars a
month and that would include utilities
and like everything like that so it's a
cheap apartment then
yeah yeah i'm gonna have a roommate he's
gonna be one of my buddies uh he's
pretty financially uh smart as well you
know he doesn't go and buy you know
thirty thousand dollars on credit cards
and eighty thousand dollar truck right
out of high school so
here's what's running through my mind
i'm trying to ask myself if i was your
dad what i would tell you to do
how would i want some or if it was me
what i would what would i do if i woke
up in your shoes
um i think i would move out
how let's run the math on this how much
more now it's not about the money yeah
it's not going to make that much you can
cover the money with the work
and you're taking the next step in your
evolution as a man and um
or if you're a lady as a lady and so um
yeah as a woman you know so in your case
as a man to to do this and i i think
that's a good thing
um
it is i think something happens
something happens developmentally when
you have to buy your own peanut butter
and bread leave and cleave you know
there's something to do yeah there's
nobody to cleave to it i know i knew you
were going to say that i got a head on
the marriage vows but the uh um but yeah
leave anyway and yeah the uh um
and it it probably cannot be
it cannot be justified in the short term
financially and i would never tell you
to borrow to do that
but you've got it figured out and you've
got such a math head on your shoulders
and such a
you know you're mature beyond your years
uh emotionally just talking to you
that's my opinion anyway and um so i
think you do this i think if you if i
thought you're a wild child and you're
just going to play beer pong i'll
probably pull the plug on this but um
i think if i i think it'll be
it's not a math
play
it's a life play i agree to do this well
said you know what i'm thinking when you
said that he's not moving out to find
himself he's moving out to be himself
he knows who he is that was good so he's
ready to go almost tweetable as if as if
anybody nicest on twitter anymore yeah
exactly all right august is in l.a
hey august how are you
hey doing great thanks for taking my
call sure welcome
my my wife and i are on baby stick uh
excuse me baby step six um i'm in uh
sales and it's been a
unusually fantastic year
so where i've made a lot more income
where i've maxed out my 401k
hsa
ira
and so my question is where are you
still not 15
pardon me is that more than 15 of your
income when it's all totaled up or less
um
it's uh it's at fifteen percent okay
right now gotcha okay so
so i've been doing 15 so now with this
extra money coming in here at the end of
the year
do i
can pay more on my house yeah
okay instead of because i was wondering
do i take
15 of these additional bonuses that'll
be coming in at the end of this year and
carrying into next year to where i may
be in the same situation depending on
some parameters
here's the thing i know by the fact that
you told me you've maxed out your 401k
and your ira that that your income is
well over 200 000
yes sir and so given that you have put a
lot into retirement this year and the
little bit extra you throw on over on
these bonuses uh into this house is not
gonna keep you from retiring with enough
nest egg it's gonna you're gonna be fine
okay and that was my thinking is i was
just wanting to put as much as we can on
the house and and
if you made a hundred thousand dollars a
year and you said i don't want to put a
full 15 in i'd like to put more on the
house i would tell you no put 15 in but
you're you're making a couple of hundred
plus here and and it's uh right here at
the end of the year and it's just a
small accounting slippage and we're
going to slippage that right over onto
the mortgage
i like that because either way you're
going to come out just fine so good
question appreciate you august
all right ken coleman good hour thank
you sir
uh of course james and ben in the booth
has that been that's not ben
who's in there
austin's in there yeah
in the glass well he's playing he's got
his incognito thing going back there
right so james and austin in the booth i
am dave ramsey your host and we'll be
back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we talk about your careers
because that's where your money comes
from that we talk about your money
and we talk about your jobs and we talk
about your money that comes from those
jobs and what to do with it so life and
money right here on the radio
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five darren is in kansas city hi
darren how are you
i'm doing great guys i really appreciate
you taking my call today our pleasure
how can we help
well i wanted to get your opinion on uh
the possibility of me selling a uh
universal variable life policy that i
have i've seen the commercials on tv
about that sort of thing
and i kind of checked out with some of
my friends or relatives and no one that
i know of has ever done it or know
anybody that's done it and i
just wanted to
see what your opinion on it would be
so you're seeing one of the commercials
where you can sell the death benefit
that pays them in the event you die
correct and i've been talking to my
financial advisor about it and uh we
were my wife and i had been thinking
about cashing in the policy anyway yeah
um
just because the market has kind of
bounced back at this point and the cash
value is
um better than it's ever been before but
i'm not sure
uh the market's going to stay that way
forever and um
i i talked my financial advisor about
possible just cashing it out and he
brought the possibility of bidding it
out to other folks that would
buy the policy
oh so your financial advisor is an
insurance agent
uh
correct he's he's actually a broker well
he's
actually agent yeah he's actually an
insurance agent because a real financial
advisor would have told you to cash that
thing out
yeah
period well i guess i think he probably
gets some sort of a commission off
i'm pretty sure yeah i'm sure he's got
somebody that he's going to uh shop it
to and he's going to get his cut and all
that but yeah yeah and he sells but he
sells life insurance that's what he does
well i don't know that he actually does
that or not i've ever purchased life
insurance from him
other than uh i've got a brokerage and
an uh an ira through him also he's not
the original uh
fellow that i
i got the policy from uh he
unfortunately passed away and i was kind
of uh turned over to this fellow a few
years back and so here's the thing okay
yeah some of the worst investment plans
in the world are any kind of cash value
life insurance
so maintaining it for any reason is not
something i'm going to recommend
if i woke up in your shoes i would
simply cash it in
you wouldn't chop it out
nope i wouldn't keep it open
i would be done with it the expenses are
too high the returns are too low
and the the insurance gets progressively
more expensive as you age
inside that thing and it eats up the
investment eventually anyway and so
no i'm getting out and i'm getting out
while the getting is good if you need
life insurance which apparently you
don't if you're getting really sell the
beneficial interest out off anyway
uh or the beneficiary's position off
anyway
then uh if you don't need life insurance
you don't need life insurance if you do
need life insurance you're going to be
much better off to buy for about a
nickel on the dollar
term
life insurance
and so i i don't uh teach people and i
never have in 30 years of doing this to
own or keep cash value insurance unless
they're sick and need insurance and
can't get any more but they already got
screwed when they bought this stuff so
they have to keep it because they're
uninsurable i would cash it out if i
were in your shoes julian is in houston
hi julian how are you
i'm doing well how are you dave better
than i deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call
so i've been in business
for about nine years now and
about three years ago my father
purchased in on half of the company and
it's grown to the point
where i'm now working out of state and
he's running things
over in the home of california and i
just recently
had someone offer me
a million dollars well 1.1 million
for my half of the business
and they wanted to ask me if i would
continue to run it out of state
but then again i wouldn't be making the
same money that i'm making now i'm
currently making 130 000
a year but i get many bonuses so it's
right around 160 to 170 and what was the
net profit on the business last year
um
right around i think 300 000
something like that
you don't know
uh well not off the top of my head
i'd have to double check the paperwork i
believe it is
okay
all right so your half is not worth a
million dollars something's wrong with
this equation
uh no it's not when we last ran the
numbers they said my business is worth
785 000
if they were to purchase it straight out
but they know that there's a lot of
potential in what we've been doing and
how we've been growing every year and
they're trying to get in on it so he
offered
to buy me out and have me run it
three times what it's worth
yes
that doesn't spook you
uh no it should not that's asinine not
so much we've uh we deal with a lot of
a lot of cash uh as well and we have
some contracts that you know make sure
that we're gonna get paid a certain
amount doesn't matter every year doesn't
matter where seven or fifty thousand are
willing to pay 2.2 million for it
or the equivalent thereof yeah the
equivalent thereof
yeah that should scare you
yeah and i don't think you want to work
for them anyway it doesn't sound like
you that's a bad idea but you don't want
to work for them at less money do you
not exactly but the idea of having that
chunk of money that'll wear off pretty
enticing i've never made that much you
know had that much in my account what do
you do
uh it's a junk removal company how old
are you
29
and why can they not get somebody else
to remove the junk
what do you mean well why do they need
you
well i don't do it personally my
employees do it yeah
so why can't you not get a manager of
people who remove junk and not need you
well they do but they know that i'm kind
of the face of the company and that i
know everyone and i have the contacts
which is why they wanted to keep me on
because i have a
good relationship with the police
department that uses us quite a bit and
with the city
the government that uses us and
they felt it'd be best if i just
continue to run it but they continue to
own it who is this
how what is your relationship to these
people
uh he owns a couple other businesses in
town and i met him through
the gym that he owns in town
i'm sorry i i
when something doesn't feel right it's
usually because it's not right
and i don't know what's wrong here but
something's wrong here yep
i can smell it in the air
and i don't know what it is
but there's something wrong
uh you don't pay three times what a
business is worth to buy half of it and
not have controlling interest in it
while the dad runs the other half
doesn't make sense man doesn't make
sense there's something wrong
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
well most people know i'm the guy who is
so dumb that i had to become a
millionaire twice
because i didn't keep it the first time
i lost everything
uh and i after losing everything i set
out to learn god's ways of handling
money and that's when we created the
ramsey baby steps
by following these steps of course i
became a millionaire many times over
again this time i did it the right way
and i spent the next three decades the
last three decades guiding millions of
people through this same plan
and today the evidence is undeniable if
you follow the baby steps you will
become a millionaire
and get to live and give like no one
else we cover all of this in a brand new
book called baby steps millionaires
first book i have done
in eight years
and it's available for pre-order right
now
you'll learn how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too the
book comes out january the 11th but if
you pre-order it we will give you over
150 worth of bonus items including the
baby steps millionaire's audiobook and
e-book the legacy journey audiobook and
e-book now
baby steps millionaires live stream
the ramsey smart tax for your federal
income tax filing free this year
ramsey plus 30 day free trial and a
bunch of other goodies
check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com pre-order baby steps
millionaires for 20 bucks and you get
all of that
tens of thousands of you have already
pre-ordered the book thank you for that
ramsey
solutions.com to get babysit's
millionaires the brand new book
very fun times joe's with us in lansing
michigan hey joe how are you
i'm awesome how are you doing today dave
just the same better than i deserve how
can i help
my wife and i are looking at moving up
in-house
our current house is paid for we'd be
paying cash for moving up
and
i'm trying to figure out how big of a
move
i guess at what point does it become
stupid
[Laughter]
okay
so what's the current house worth
about 250. and what uh what is the house
you're talking about moving into that's
questionable on stupid price wise
maybe between five and seven hundred and
you've got that much cash how much total
cash do you have
um
so we have a net worth of about 800 000
250 of it in our house about 100 between
a little rental and our checking account
and then about 250 and a brokerage and
the rest in retirement
so if it were 500 roughly we could move
up you know sell our house and do it oh
you're selling the house okay all right
so your total
you would have a net worth of around 800
and over half of it would be in your
personal residence
uh yeah that's where we'd be if we moved
up yeah and and your household income is
one may be 75
yeah depending on the year 180 to 230
and how old are you guys
we're in our mid-30s
no i don't think that's crazy
because i don't think your net worth is
your house is going to be 50 to 60 of
your net worth for very long because
house will go up in value from this
point forward but you're going to be
aggressively adding to
investments and so your investments are
going to be at a million pretty quick
i mean i'd agree with that five to seven
years you should have a million dollars
plus your house right
at which point you'd be about a third
the average person that we found in the
millionaire study when we studied ten
thousand millionaires uh here normal we
found out just thousands and thousands
of them that had a 1.5 million dollar
net worth and 500 in a house and a
million in their retirement account
but the and but the average was 49 years
old too
okay so that that's your that's kind of
what i'm gauging this off of you're
young you have a big income that's going
to you're going to be more than that by
the time you're 49
um and so this is not out of line now if
you told me you made
60 000 a year
and you were 65
i'd be a little worried about this
because you'd be kind of stuck there
with your house being more than half
your annual in or half your net worth
and that's a lot to have tied up in your
net worth because your house does not
create an
income right
at retirement and um so it just prevents
you from house payments all it does and
so yeah in your case you're young you
got a lot of
up ramp a lot of a lot of uh on-ramp to
go and you're going to be fine i would
do that
see how i did that yeah
that's very good i think it's really
smart because of the age factor and the
house itself i mean it's it's going to
end up being a really good ratio well
with 180 000 income of 30 years old he
ought to build yeah and the house is not
gonna right he's not spending more on
the house it's not changing that yeah
evelyn's in albuquerque new mexico hi
evelyn welcome to the ramsey show
hi mr andy how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so
my company just sent out a message uh
yesterday that um they're 401k they
normally match it up to six percent
and for the year of 2022 they're still
going to match it however the caveat is
that they're gonna do it in a lump sum
in 2023
and then if i leave my job during 2022 i
get none of the 401k match so first off
i was wondering if that's even like a
normal theme at all or if
um this is something new
and how to move forward in terms of that
it's weird
meaning that it's not a normal thing
companies do
um have you guys had a lot of turnover
um yes
okay well they've they've had a great
resignation and they're sick of giving
people money
that are walking out the door that's
what they're doing that's exactly right
this is a retention move
golden handcuffs move
that's why they're i understand why
they're doing it i i get why they're
doing it and there's nothing immoral or
or it is unusual it's not a typical way
you run a 401k
uh i kind of like it a little bit though
if they've had a ton of turnover because
i understand as the owner i don't want
to give a bunch of people money they're
walking out the door the purpose of
giving people money in their 401k is to
keep them around
it's a benefit you know
and so i think the largest turnover is
just from kovac because there really
wasn't that much turnover until coveted
hit but i think yeah i know but they've
had this great resignation stuff
following covid
uh people got people got in freak out
mode or they suddenly realize they're
gonna die so they go have to go live
their best life or whatever and and
they're you know they're they're hitting
the door man like crazy and we're not
having much of that at ramsey but we are
sure seeing all the numbers especially
ken coleman and his world so
um do you like your job is there
anything else wrong over there
um
there are a couple of um
do you plan to move do you plan to leave
next year
possibly
well there's why it comes which is why i
was also wondering is do i just
not put in the six percent into the 401k
and just move it over
instead into like a roth ira instead of
um expecting and hoping for their match
well there's no downside you don't get a
match on your roth ira if you put it in
a roth 401k you don't get a match but
you might get a match if you stay
right there's no downside to doing it it
doesn't cost you anything that's weird
yeah there's a vibe going on inside that
culture in there yeah
and i understand
i to with you i completely understand
well i mean the firings will continue
till the morale improves that's what
this is right that's exactly right so
it's like on one hand i get why they're
doing it but it's not going to help
their problem it's not no no i well
they're just trying to keep from
uh
feeling taken advantage of yes and
leadership i mean i i get the idea but
um
but it's like it's like you i mean we
have turnover here
we don't have a lot nothing like that
but the point is when you hire somebody
that's that's kind of the risk of doing
business if you want to invest in people
and and they're going to leave you and
and so that that's just part of the
thing i think if they keep doing this
it's going to end up hampering the
leadership um i get why they're doing it
but i don't think it's a great move no
it's not it's because it sends a wrong
signal right
yeah it's
you
[Music]
you just seldom mess up loving people
well
you know that's true i think that's what
sometimes you do sometimes you get
misunderstood and sure a lot about and
all that i don't know anybody like that
but
um but the um but you seldom mess up
living you don't when you're 78 9 and 89
living on laying on your death bed you
don't regret going i did the right thing
so yeah i'm with you i don't think the
company ought to do that but it really
doesn't affect whether you put money
into it or not because you're not going
to get any match if you put it somewhere
else
and if you don't stay obviously you
won't get any match but if you do stay
you might get the match so i probably
put it in there
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this job hunting can be stressful
and time consuming but my friends at
ziprecruiter have made the whole job
search way easier ziprecruiter is rated
the number one job site in the us by g2
and it's free so how does it work first
go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
lately best-selling author of the book
from paycheck from paycheck to purpose
you know the preposition is a little
different from paycheck to purpose and
you try to remember i always say
paycheck to purpose but it works it
works
yeah i have to have to get that straight
in my head i own the book i should
probably i should since it's my
publishing company i should probably get
the dead gum title right
it's like forgetting your kid's birthday
all right
up next is gonna be chris and amanda
they're in sherwood oregon says on my
screen you guys are debt-free congrats
thanks dave thanks dave way to go how
much did you pay off
uh we paid off 121
607.29 months way to go and your range
of income during that 29 months
uh we started about 126 000 uh current
income 184 000. whoa nice jump what do
you guys do for a living
um i work in tech and uh she works in
corporate retail cool very cool what
kind of debt was the 122
000
a little bit everything uh two car loans
credit cards student loans personal
loans store credit cards oh my gosh
y'all were normal
yeah you got it yep that's horrible how
long have you been married
oh geez
since 2007 yep
okay so 14 years of marriage but two and
a half years ago
things changed
and you decided to go crazy for 29
months and pay off 122
000 what happened how did you get
connected to us and why did you start
this journey
you know um actually dave i found uh
rachel on a podcast
and
i
everything she said just sort of clicked
and
she talked about how
just feeling out of control
and i
came home and said this is something we
need to try so
we
got
fbu got the financial peace university
and
and started the journey and knew that we
didn't want to feel like that anymore
and didn't want to feel out of control
and and we knew we made
money but we didn't know where it went
yeah
and that was the big unlock for us it's
like having a a financial hangover
yeah yeah there's all there's all this
regret you know in your head hurts you
know it's like where'd it all go
so uh chris amanda says she's been
listening this podcast and she found
this new plan what did you say
well
i guess at first i was a little
skeptical but you know amanda tells me
to do something i usually do it so yeah
there we go
happy wife
and it was it was no turning back after
you start seeing those deaths come off
it's
you know it's it's gung-ho all the way
it is addicting isn't it
oh absolutely um we definitely got very
addicted to opening up the every dollar
app and
checking and we there was there was
never a dollar or a cent that we didn't
have a conversation about to the point
where like something came out like on
accident and i was like oh my goodness
did you see that that wasn't supposed to
happen
we we were so in tune with
what the jobs that are that our money
was doing for us that's good that's good
that's why you got there so fast
well done very well done yeah i want to
know because you guys talked about
catching that pretty quickly and going
okay this was this was fun take us in
the journey of the 29 months how early
into that journey did you all feel like
okay
now we've gotten past the discipline and
we've figured it out and now we're
experiencing tremendous momentum how
early did that take place
i would say i would say about three
months yeah three months in you know i
think that that's kind of those those
bumps that you get through where you
know maybe that that first month of
estimating your uh the what you need for
your gas we were a little off um or we
forgot about a birthday or we forgot
about something
you know that we needed put as a line
item in the budget and then
after we sort of honed in on on how we
could
uh kind of win
it was really easy to just start seeing
that those debts come down and that
snowball just getting bigger and bigger
and just rolling down the hill yeah once
you get those first few credit cards off
and those payments go away it's
hard to look back after that point yeah
now that you're free how's it feel
it's amazing it's it's it's so amazing i
mean i think you know i've had i had
this moment where i i realized like what
the word peace meant in you know
financial peace university and for me it
was
you know we had we had an emergency in
the family happen you know my mom got
sick and we needed to
kind of react and i needed to fly back
home to chicago where we're from
and
the amazing thing was we didn't have to
think about what credit card we needed
to put a flight on we didn't need to
think about
how i needed to get there and how we
needed a fly family out to oregon to
come and help us
that was the piece and we were able to
focus on her and not the crisis and the
money that normally would come with an
emergency and we didn't even need at
that point to dip into our emergency
fund it was it was no big deal yeah and
that's i think what what helped us
know that we were
so on the right path
amen well done way to go heroes very
very good job all right so what do you
tell people the key the thing you got to
do the two things you got to do the
three things you got to do if you want
to get out of debt is
budget
for me it's budget all the way budget
and you know i talk and talk i think
that was the big thing that i have said
to people that that we've uh shared the
the weird with and and given you know a
total money makeover and and passed the
book along and pass the budget tool
along
is that this is not it's not just about
money it's about your marriage and it
has made our marriage so much stronger
we
there's not a moment that we don't have
that conversation and we don't talk
about it so those are the keys to
winning yeah that's very good very good
well done y'all well done good stuff
well we've got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book which comes out
january the 11th but i know a guy we're
going to send you an early release copy
oh amazing because that's the next
chapter in your story to go on and
become
baby steps millionaires now that you're
out of debt you're on your way to do
that
that's the purpose to live and give like
no one else and you'll be in great shape
to do that also gonna send you a copy
the total money makeover which you can
give away to someone and help them learn
the stuff you've learned and get on this
path
amazing thank you well way to go you
guys
chris and amanda sherwood oregon 122
000 paid off in 29 months making 126 to
184 count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
one
two three
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it is done
that's how it's done
so if you want to do
something you've never done you're going
to have to if you want to go to some
place you've never been you have to do
something you've never done
you can't keep doing the same thing over
and over again and expect a different
result that's the definition of insanity
and so you need a proven
clear
path and that's what the baby steps are
in
business and that's what the steps that
you lay out in from paycheck to purpose
are on getting a new job that's right
it's a clear proven path the first step
is get clear that's right and
in your paycheck to purpose system and
uh one of the things we've discovered
here at ramsey is that the best
probability of you having a life
transforming
event happen is to give you a clear path
to get there yeah do this then do this
then do this and you'll get there yeah
you know i was i was listening to amanda
and amanda i i think she preached and
she didn't realize it she she talked
about
never really understanding what peace
meant you know we say financial peace
and i know you choose words very
intentionally and when she said that i
thought you know peace means a lot of
different things specifically within
people's journeys but you know i i'm a
word nerd you know that i just i pulled
up the definition and it says freedom
from disturbance
tranquility and i thought tranquility
that's the one yeah i really love that a
calm no matter what the disturbance is
family member dies
we don't have any disturbance we're a
little peace in
this society today
there's a premium on it very few
peaceful
people very few peaceful situations
very few buildings that you walk in that
you get a sense of peace
everything's so frenetic and so angry
and so divided
and everybody's pissed off about
something
wow
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author as we talk to you about careers
and money
because that's where money comes from is
careers and so how that how you handle
your money is tied to the money you make
how much money you make how well you do
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five tim is in
charlotte north carolina hi tim how are
you
doing all right how are you doing better
than i deserve how can we help sir
i'm doing that right um
so
basically uh kind of my little situation
here i'm 19
currently
cash flowing my way through school
the only debt that i currently have is
in a
car payment for 17 grand and
i love everything about the car don't
get me wrong but
um
i love everything about it except for
the price and
i really wanna um like basically me and
my mom are co-signed under the same loan
i really want to trade it in and
basically get like a
used car
um something that i can that i can do
for
work and school
but i just it's it's so
the way my parents are they don't want
me to trade in the car they'd rather
have me have a new car and pay off the
debt like they want me to pay off the
bet
but i mean i really want to sell it so
basically my question is how do i get
them on the same page
so i guess i could
get it get it going out of my life
wow
um whose name is on the car
uh it's um both my mom and um
on the title or on the left side
on the loan whose name's on the title
uh is
my mom's name under the title
so your mom owns the car
yeah yeah practically yep yep no she
does
legally she owns the car
the car's title to her
okay and uh you owe nineteen thousand on
it
i own uh seventeen thousand seven
thousand what's it worth
um
guy kelly blue
well i went to kelly blue book last
night and
um they said it was at 25 um through
dealership so
private i could probably get
like 27 28 for it
and that would give you the cash to buy
a car assuming your mom let you have the
cash from the sale of her car
basically yes yeah
okay do you live at home and i mean
yeah i live at home um
yeah and this is something that i use
you know every day for commute
um like i mean i drive
um like 30 minutes each way you know to
work and back and then you know schools
and other
um 15 minutes out of my way and yeah i i
i don't
i mean i i put quite a bit of miles on
my car
how many um
my mom's part-time what do you make a
year or what are you making what kind of
my income are you making
um right now i'm a i guess i princess
welder so i don't make too much i only
make 15 an hour right now
so whatever that adds up to
and what are you going to school for
going to school for welding
okay when will you graduate
uh be graduating summer of next year
with my certificate do you have any
money saved
that's in your
account yeah i mean i i have a um a
thousand dollars like basically a
thousand dollars saved up because i've
been i've been uh
kind of chunking away at the debt who's
paying for something
i'm paying for school currently
it's very interesting
well
the first place we start is with
persuasion
and with respect
mom and dad thank you you've been a huge
blessing to me
what i need you guys to understand is
that this car is stressing me out
it is not a blessing
i know you want me to have a nice car
and i understand that i cannot stand
this debt anymore i'm getting anxiety
from this debt i'm freaking out because
of this debt i've got to get this debt
off of me
you've got to sell this car mom
yeah and i would just add to that i
think that's great i would just add a
little bit of vision to the persuasion
i'd show her all the different kind of
quality cars you can get right now for
ten thousand dollars assuming you sell
it for 27 yo 17. show her some other
nice dependable cars now we can get a
nice car for ten thousand dollars i
won't have any payments
and then when i finish school i'll be
able to walk out of here and get my
welding job and get out on my own with
no car payments and this is scaring me
to death i i cannot sleep i've got
anxiety this is driving me nuts mom and
dad i need you to let me
loose set your people free
yes yeah yeah and like my plan my plan
originally was to me graduate debt-free
my like my goal is to
um you know have fifty thousand dollars
cash by the time i'm twenty-four so that
you know when i move out i have a good
down payment and you're not gonna you're
gonna move out long before then you're
gonna move out long before then yeah
because you're gonna you're gonna have
your full-time job after you graduate
and you don't need to live at home
anymore i mean you'll be fine
you you know you'll be making a lot of
money as a welder you're gonna be an
apprentice anymore and you won't have
any car payments because you're going to
talk them into this
the second thing you can do but it
starts to get nasty is um
mom i'm not paying the payments anymore
on your car
the car's in your name it's your problem
i'm not gonna pay the payments anymore
yeah i ask you nicely to sell it i told
you it's stressing me out and it's the
net the car is in your name so you can
do whatever you wanna do with your car
mom um at which point you're going to
figure out how to get a car
and you may have to figure out a place
to live because they may put you out
um because you know you're under their
roof
so um but that you know or you may have
to just wait till summer to get rid of
the car
uh when you move out that would be the
time to get rid of the car and then you
can play that hand mom i asked you to
get rid of it now i'm just telling you
here's the keys to your car
and good luck with that car send your
name
and um and she'll sell the car and
she'll be
angry at her ungrateful son
but um that that's after you said please
please please sell it i'm stressed out i
can't stand this dead and she couldn't
hear you because
um
she's a bit controlling at that point
um and so i don't know i hope it doesn't
go that direction there's a whole i
don't think it will dave i think that
was great advice and i i i think it's uh
i think it's both and i like your first
tack
and and i like the second one it's he
presents them both at the same time
so mom we either sell this because of
all the things you described and you
also can say look here's what i can buy
it's a very dependable car and i'm going
to take the money i've been paying
towards the loan and here's how much
money i'm going to be able to save up
cast a vision um because i think she's
controlling because of some type of fear
she has yeah and i think when he shows
that second scenario or mom then
technically it is yours and i'm going to
start taking the money i've been paying
towards the loan i'm gonna save up for a
car for a beater and eventually get a 10
000 or whatever i think he i think he
forces that to let her have to deal with
what my baby doesn't want the car on
people i think it's going to work in his
favor yeah
yeah and that's what you know
but
that that's the thing that's the thing
so it's weird what's going on with a
parent who'll go no i'd rather pay debt
payments on a car because they think
that they're always going to have debt
and they're teaching them a lesson on
how to handle debt it's just stupid
ben is with us ben
[Laughter]
it's true though ben's going to be up in
another hour
not this hour so um but anyway yeah i
because he wants to pay it off he wants
to sell it and they're going no
here's the thing so you think that's
conditioning yeah it's mom and dad
believe it yeah they they don't believe
they're bringing harm to him right of
course no no no yeah yeah they they
think he's just being silly and naive
well you're always going to have a
payment son so you might as well just
understand that now wow and um you know
because a lot of people believe that
yeah and that leaves them in this
situation so the main thing tim is don't
be disrespectful
don't be angry
don't be unkind
and don't be ungrateful
i'm very grateful for what you've done
here but i just can't do this anymore
it's breaking the back of my spirit it's
killing me and i just can't do it
anymore set your people free please
and i i think if you go that way that
you can at least get hurt and add to
that what ken was saying and that is
uh here's a vision of where we're going
i mean you can take the money from the
car the equity in this car it's an
unusual time in the car markets buy a
ten thousand dollar car that'll do
everything this car does
um you're 19 years old in a 25 000 car
making fifteen dollars an hour at his
age i was driving a car that had three
hundred thousand miles on dollars an
hour
how did you think this was a blessing
uh
puts this hour the ramsey show in the
books
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
[Music]
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality best-selling author
of the book paycheck to purpose
host of the ken coleman show which is
now broadcast on over 80 radio stations
xm radio sirius xm radio as well as a
very popular podcast
he talks every day about making your
shovel larger by getting promoted
getting a different job
thinking differently about the income
side of the equation so we're going to
talk about income side as well as out go
side here talking about your money and
your life and your career this hour the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five
triple eight eight two five five
two two five ben is in pittsburgh hey
ben how are you
dave and ken um i was calling to get
your advice on a potential career change
i spent the last 10 years
in public accounting i've also earned my
master's and my cpa during that time on
the last two years i've spent uh selling
real estate part time and just
considering making a jump full time
uh in the past few years i've obviously
worked doing both and i really enjoyed
the real estate aspect of things and and
i've also quadrupled my business uh from
2020 to 2021 wow i guess i'm just uh
just nervous about making the jump and i
wanted to get your guys thoughts on it
yeah well what are you making in
accounting
um somewhere around 115. and what are
you making in real estate last year um
yeah in 2021 i'll end up around 130 on a
full-time basis
yeah
uh i was getting ready to say that
you're in a very unique situation where
you've been doing it on the side for
long enough that you've built not only
your portfolio but your pipeline your
actual income is there you have nothing
to be nervous about you have officially
done what i want people to do which is
try to replace six months of your income
before you move forward right but you've
done more than that i think it's time
man i'm really curious to know what
you're afraid of specifically and i'm
not asking you to
call you out to embarrass you but i
really want to hear what you're afraid
of based on the fact that you're making
more
in real estate part-time
than you are in your full-time
accounting job what are you afraid of
um i think in general it's just the you
know you hear the market taught i don't
want to i guess get false sense of
security
um and then i guess i have trouble
thinking about like what the worst case
scenario is obviously i've listened to
you guys for a number of years um i'm
debt free with the exception of the
mortgage i'm just obviously conservative
in nature and like i said just just
overall nervous i guess yes in this past
year obviously doubled my income yeah um
what is the worst case scenario let's
truly identify i think you know what it
is play it out what's the worst case
scenario
of you switching full-time real estate
i don't know trying to unpack that i
think
yeah
so here's the deal the worst case
scenario will be far-fetched for you the
worst case scenario is you stop working
the worst case scenario is people stop
buying and selling houses it's really
far-fetched and i'm not trying to be
silly i'm trying to help you see that
you're a very conservative guy by nature
that's that is the insurance against
some of the stuff that you're worried
about because the true worst case
scenario is so far-fetched it's not even
plausible so i would tell you the time
is now move when you want to because
here's what i know
uh when you go into full-time real
estate
you you should double your income triple
your income and not the not too distant
future because it's hard to win in
part-time real estate i mean to really
really win and you figured it out
everybody i know that that says real
estate is the play they say to really
truly win you're going to need to go
full time and when you do that i think
it's going to be exponential when you're
running a business
or you're
on straight commission which you will be
a little bit of desperation is good for
the soul
so a certain amount of healthy respect
type fear
i have a healthy respect for this is
dangerous if i don't play it right
that will drive you and you'll make 200
000 your first year
got it
now don't don't allow that fear or that
healthy respect or that healthy level of
desperation to become debilitating
because your anxiety gets so high
that you start shutting down from it
okay
because there's nothing in this math or
logic or critical thinking process that
you've got in front of us that says you
should panic
there's nothing here but it is always
good
to have a healthy
respect i'll give you an example okay
you have a healthy respect for the
accounting firm that you work for
that should you
decide not to come to work for five days
with no explanation and uh they can't
get a hold of you they're probably going
to fire you
right
yep then so the healthy respect says
i'm going to communicate i'm going to
work i'm going to do my part
and it's not a because there's natural
consequences that are negative
to not carrying out and carrying playing
through
and that's all this is yeah that's all
this is and so the difference is when
you go from being an accountant to being
straight commission
that feels like it's a lot more risk but
all we're doing here is just trading one
healthy respect for another one yeah you
have to make the sales calls you have to
do the stuff you've been doing and you
got to hustle and you got to grind and
you got an extra 40 hours to do it now
and you're going to make 200 your first
year you're going to be fine yes go get
it and congratulations yeah well done
what he's done well he's impressive well
played grace is in boston hi grace
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how's it going great what's up
so i've been listening the past couple
of days and i heard you talking about
not loaning money to family and how that
almost always creates a negative dynamic
yes um but i started a new business this
year that's been really successful and i
really want to find a way that is good
to share that success with my family a
little bit wonderful so what my husband
and i thought of was setting up 529
accounts for our five nieces
and i wanted to know if you think
there's a difference between giving
money and loaning money when it comes to
family and if that would be okay that
would be wonderful and yes there's a
huge difference between giving money and
loaning money
and with a 529 you can set yourself as
the custodian so that you're in actual
control of the money for the on behalf
of the child
perfect and then eventually switch it to
their parents or keep myself as a
custodian sure either way
you don't have to but i mean if their
parents are responsible you can set them
up as you want to but you lose control
then and it's okay if you lose control
that's what giving is about you're
supposed to lose control
okay cool okay great i'm glad that you
approve yeah the dynamic does not change
unless the person starts to be entitled
on the other end and you're
funding negative behavior
indirectly you're giving a drunk a drink
with your gift
and that's not what you're talking about
here that's not even in the parent it's
not even in the
in the in the scope of this discussion
but but that's a time where giving is
not the same as loaning but we're giving
can actually be negative or you're
funding negative behavior
uh we don't give a drunk a drink it's
not good for the drunk
and we're not blessing them but that's
different than the drunk owes us money
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well guys it's almost time for christmas
merry christmas
i love it
it's so fun if i didn't know you were
gonna do that i got you the hat
uh hey there's some of you out there
missing out on the joy of the season
because all you got stress
all you're worried about is presence and
food and traveling you don't have the
money for any of it
uh well it doesn't have to be this way
you can have a plan for your money you
can have confidence you can have
financial peace
we'll show you how to do all that in
financial peace university how to get
out of debt how to save money how to
become wealthy and how to be
outrageously generous wouldn't it be
cool to be in that place it is cool to
be in that place
in fact the average household saves 2
700 when they're going through financial
peace university and they pay off fifty
three hundred dollars in debt in the
first ninety days that's an eight
thousand dollar change in position in
ninety days
now financial peace university is a
ramsey plus membership feature
so you want to go through financial
business university you join ramsey plus
but there you are just like that that's
how it works and you get of course every
dollar the premium version that ties to
your bank so you don't have to have
stressed out christmas you don't have to
be stressed out you can learn how to do
this we'll show you how
either give financial peace university
as a gift or
sign up for it for yourself and let's
make 2022 the year that you straighten
yourself out ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's how you'll find it
slash
ramseysolutions.com
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means if you
pick the wrong color you pick the wrong
blinds you mess up measuring they're
gonna replace it free you got free
samples free shipping new promos every
month always use the promo code ramsey
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from amanda in dallas she
asked i'm doing research in preparation
for negotiating my salary during my
annual review if you look at the median
salary of my current and past rolls i
made nearly the exact amount listed
online does this mean it would be
inappropriate for me to negotiate a new
salary if not how then do i overcome the
feeling that the act of negotiating is
overstepping especially when i'm
extremely grateful for the income i
currently earn okay we got all the wrong
words here amanda i love the question
number one it's not inappropriate for
you to talk about salary in an annual
review i would hope in a healthy company
that that is going to be discussed uh in
some form or fashion anyway i would take
the term negotiate out i don't like
negotiating that's that's when i'm
purchasing something or we're in a
hostage crisis i think communicating is
the word and and if you've done the
research on the median salary and you
can show your leader with a great
posture so first of all it's not wrong
secondly let's work on our posture hey
after they've gone through their normal
annual review told you what you can do
better you've asked questions on how you
can add more value say hey i'd love to
talk about income i did a little bit of
research i'm extremely grateful to be
here and so i'm just wondering um could
we talk about a growth plan
that includes me adding more value maybe
assuming more responsibility
and measuring that and tying a comp plan
to that now you don't have to do it word
for word that way but there's a spirit
there and there's also not an ask
for something there's a there's a
request for the leader to weigh in with
you and build a performance-based
comp structure that would allow you to
grow because you've added value to the
organization i'd like to see you do that
but i think with that research it makes
it
a whole lot less tense when you can show
the median and then work with them on a
plan that's the approach that i always
tell folks don't negotiate don't ask for
a salary ask for growth opportunities
that aren't just
income growth uh responsibility
influence and measurables if you're
coming at this with a spirit that ken's
talking about of
i'm not
taking something
i'm adding something yes
and you smile yeah
how can i become more valuable
so that my income can go up
that's right
and smile yeah right and shut up right
90
something percent of the people doing
the review if they have it within their
power
to change your compensation and most of
the time they do
will be highly uncomfortable
it's awkward on the other side of the
show it sure is
and they're gonna go wait a minute this
lady is in front of me she's very
valuable she does a great job she's not
a twerp like the guy i just did the
review for a few minutes ago
uh
wow
i really want to do something nice for
this nice person
and that's how it feels on the other
side it's true and they're going to go
well um um well what what what what can
i do like they're gonna it's gonna turn
right back on them and they're gonna
feel the pressure
to do something without you having
putting pressure on them at all because
um
you know because the thing is sitting
right there in front of them it's that
simple
um
and and if you change it to the
juxtaposition and you say uh well i'm
mark salento then that's the the
opposite of of the gratitude and the
opposite of the pleasantness
uh and it's an entitled arrogant
thing that's going to pretty much
guarantee that not only you're not going
to get the raise your employment's
probably
stunted there at a minimum maybe leaving
there no question that approach puts
them on the defensive the approach that
you and i just talked about allows them
to take some ownership of the situation
and they feel the pressure they do good
pressure good pressure it's like this is
a good person i want to be good to a
good person and by the way the way we
just described that you won't believe
the response just because very few
people come about
compensation increases that way yeah
they just come and go i did the research
and i'm making the meeting i've been
here eight years and you can say with a
sweet spirit and say all that but with
the sweet spirit but still come across
the wrong way yep
yep it's uh it's
it's really a relational iq thing is
what it comes down to rachel's with us
rachel is in houston texas hi rachel how
are you
hi good thank you for taking my call
certainly how can we help
so i have a tender offer on some stock i
own in a private company that i used to
work for
um i've gone back and forth whether i
should try to
sell all of the stock i own since you
advise not to own single stock what's it
worth
it is worth four hundred thousand i paid
five
yeah
it's a big gain so i've debated pulling
enough out to pay off my house or
pulling it all out
paying off my house and then investing
the rest so
just looking to get some advice
this is a
you said a tendered offer so this is not
a publicly traded company
no no private so you did mention that
and so it's very difficult to trade this
stock unless you have an offer tendered
yes not very liquid at all
okay right
uh who
does the uh
person who the founder or someone like
that own controlling interest in the
company
um i'm not entirely sure i don't work
there anymore
did it used to be i mean it's a yes yes
they've done very very well but they're
in control
okay so
here's the thing
you've made a lot of money
congratulations
thank you that's wonderful
and what does it take to pay off your
home
um 215.
okay
and so if i put 185 000 or so in the
middle of your kitchen table with your
home already paid off
and i said okay
you can do anything you want to do this
185 000 one thing you could do is you
could buy stock
in a privately held company where the
founder has controlling interest and if
he loses or she loses his mind they're
going to drive the thing into the ground
or it could double
but either way it's going to be
difficult to sell it you have to wait on
a tendered offer it's not very liquid
it's not very accessible
this is called a high risk play
it is yes it's a and so far it's paid
off beautifully the danger of that is it
makes you not realize how much risk is
involved here
uh yeah i would not put
20 cents in this company even though it
has done very well uh
because i don't like this guy he's got
he's over he's got complete control
behind the curtain
uh and and you know it's it's not
because he's doing something to crooked
i don't mean that but he could just
decide to run the thing in the dirt he
could make several wrong decisions or
one big wrong decision and make your
fortune go away i'm cashing out 100 for
that reason
paying off your house and moving the
rest of it to mutual funds or to some
other investment this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
he is author of the best-selling book
recently just came out called
from paycheck to purpose be sure you get
one so you can move from paycheck to
purpose and more paychecks too andrew is
with us and melissa and they are in
grand rapids michigan i see on my screen
you guys are debt-free congratulations
thank you hey thanks dave we appreciate
it so much very cool how much of you
guys paid off
77
248 dollars way to go and your range of
how long did this take
about 17 months wow range of income
during that time
uh we started at about 107 000 and we
ended around about 152 000 very good
what do y'all do for a living
so i am a project manager for a
construction company
and melissa is a realtor oh very good
good combo one-two punch
yeah so what kind of debt was the 77 000
oh a lot of it was school debt
and then
it was tax debt from being a real estate
agent and not doing my taxes very well
um we had some car debt and some credit
card debt too kind of normal
yep yeah pretty pretty normal how long
you guys been married
uh we got married in october 2019 just
celebrated two years oh okay so you got
married and decided to attack this debt
and get it cleaned up it sounds like it
all happened at once
yeah we started taking the class four
months after we got married
oh you took financial peace university
we did we did very good
cool so right so you're newlyweds we go
to the money class what was that like
oh man
it was uh it was it was quite
eye-opening for us but i tell you what
it was
it uh it opened up so many doors of
opportunity for us and it really allowed
us to
be able to come together as newly was
and we really were able to
grow in our prayer life and grow in our
in our marriage through being able to
take on you know what is such a
something that is such a stressful
situation with financial as you
mentioned on your show
with marriage we were able to
combat that together and that brought so
much more peace to our marriage and to
our finances yeah
wow
very cool
very cool well congratulations you guys
well thank you thank you dave thank you
we appreciate it it's been quite the
trip i mean getting rid of the irs
getting rid of credit cards this is a
peaceful situation
it absolutely is yes it is yeah from
from having to uh from having to handle
all that stress to uh forming our plan
and and uh taking everything step by
step and thinking staying faithful to
uh the plan and faithful in our prayer
and faithful to the program
that that allowed us to uh to really
come through it wasn't something that uh
happened overnight and it was very tough
but we uh we stayed faithful and god
always continued to provide
wow i love that so this is a lot of
money 77 000 17 months this is getting
with it and so you said the class you
guys went in there it was really
eye-opening i want to know what you guys
did how did you get so much momentum how
did you pay off so much what were some
of the did you sell some stuff was it
making more money what was going on
yeah so essentially our plan was we sat
down and we strategized a plan to take
half of all of melissa's commission
income and we just put that directly
towards paying off all the debt i had a
steady income with my job as a project
manager
and so everything that we made with
millis's income we took half of that and
we put that towards towards the debt and
it wasn't easy there were multiple there
were multiple months where
where we were concerned and we were
wondering if we'd be able to uh to pay
off our mortgage our mortgage payment
for that month um but uh and like like i
said staying faithful and in our tithing
and faithful in our prayer um we didn't
miss a single payment and uh
god brought us through in so many
incredible ways wow wow very cool guys i
mean you did you stepped and fetched so
again what do you tell people the key
somebody says all right i need the
master class on getting out of debt you
went through financial peace university
you pay off 77 000 in 17 months this
makes you experts what do you tell them
the key is to getting out of debt
well i think the key is to have a plan
because if you don't have a plan
you don't have anywhere to start
yeah so we sat down after the first
couple classes and we're like okay how
do we
how do we get you know baby step number
two get rid of all of our debt
you know um so we just had to kind of
shift our our mindset and our hearts
desires and just make the sacrifice
um
you know with half of our income being
just shoved over to the debt side yeah
wow guys way to go very cool
congratulations
your heroes i'm so proud of you well
done who are your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you so um so what uh
when we started our financial peace
class uh matt and amy wengler
were our teachers and they've been on
your show before they've actually
visited the office and they were key
influences for us they
they actually came to our real estate
office and uh spoke to all the realtors
and shared how they became millionaires
through your program
yes sir yeah and that really gave us
such a motivation to see their start to
finish to create our own start to finish
and uh so much so it influenced us to
where i'm actually now co-leading uh the
fpu class at our church with matt and uh
it's been great it's been great well
thank you that's very cool hearing it
from the mouths of other people like
they're real millionaires they did it
that is some validation yeah that'll say
let's do it game on man
this is good very yeah we hope to follow
in their footsteps oh well you are
there's no question you're right on your
way i mean you guys have you jumped on
this with both feet you're kicking it
around making it behave i'm so proud of
y'all well done
hey we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you the book comes out
january the 11th but uh we're gonna send
you an advanced copy because uh just
like you talked about you guys are
getting ready to be there yes you're
heading that direction that's the next
chapter in your story so very well done
so very well done also a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away and uh maybe help somebody get
started while you're teaching the class
and everything way to go
andrew and melissa grand rapids michigan
77 000 dollars paid off in 17 months
making 107 to 152 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
there you go one two three we're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
love it
so well done
so well done man that is everything it
takes to go win right there yeah and you
can't help but pay it forward then you
can't upset i'm going to go over here
and teach financial peace university
class i'm going to be a coordinator i'm
gonna pay for somebody to go through
because you realize it just takes a a
little bit of effort to get somebody
really going if they if they got the
right stuff you can light them on fire
oh
and that's what's so awesome about this
is that you know it's just like anything
else in life if you if you're uh you
have a meal at some place or you you uh
experience a new product and you really
are impacted by it you can't wait to
tell others about it or share with
others and he's like man i've already
signed up i'm coordinating and they're
gonna be ones that are telling stories
hey we're we're baby steps millionaires
and here's how we did it and some some
couple that's never even heard of us is
going to go baby steps millionaires
what's that what what's that
and that's how it just keeps
multiplying exactly because testimony is
powerful yeah you know it changes
everything and it just it gives you hope
yeah
in a world that's gone crazy in a world
is just angry and divided and
mean and nasty and trying to find some
way to push something down instead of
lift something up you know and uh you
find a chance here to just be good to
somebody just love them well yeah you
know that's just good it's good stuff
that's the way it is that's where it
should be that is so very cool here's
the thing
some of you are tuning in for the very
first time i've been doing this 30 years
and you're just now finding this
and you think it's an accident it's not
an accident
you heard that particular call right
then where they do their debt-free
screamer from grand rapids michigan
which by the way the very first debt
free scream came from grand rapids is
that right that's where the lady was
from oh that's cool yeah
we didn't intend for it to be a
debt-free scream we just couldn't stop
her right she was so fired up one of the
great stories of all time yeah
she called in and she's like i paid off
in that i paid off my dad i paid off my
dad i sold everything i was having a
garage sale on the guy about the bushes
out of the front of my house i'm
debt-free i'm debt-free i'm that free
and she hung up that was the first debt
free scream
i had no control over the call she
machine-gunned me
it was just great it was so fabulous
that's where it all started yeah and the
guy called in two weeks later goes hey i
won't do that you know so we let him and
there you go man
why not man yeah why not let's do it
let's celebrate i don't care
hey you know if you if you do something
good somebody ought to say something
that's a good thing well done this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 27 14
wait for the lord be strong and take
heart and wait
for the lord
samuel johnson said self-confidence is
the first requisite to great
undertakings
wow
haley is with us in springfield missouri
hi haley welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
hey so my husband and i are on baby step
number two we're about twenty five
thousand dollars paid off of seventy
five
thousand and
um we have a check for about three
thousand dollars coming in it's
for my son technically in our name
he was born early i had preeclampsia and
he was in the nicu for two months and so
we have a little bit of supplemental
income coming for him
but i just wanted to know if we should
apply it to debt or if we should start
maybe a fund for him
well
three thousand dollars one time
it's actually from social security
supplemental income from the past two
years that we didn't really know about
it was often some
on a card that we did not know about we
just found out about it today okay so it
had built up to three thousand dollars
yes okay is there any more coming after
this
no this is it okay
okay um i i i don't want to sound
snobbish or here for you to hear this
wrong but mathematically it doesn't
matter
it's three thousand dollars i kind of
thought you might say that yeah it's not
three hundred thousand dollars it's
three hundred thousand dollars we have
an existential crisis here we have to
figure this out but with three thousand
dollars it doesn't matter what you do
with it it's not you've not done
anything wrong now here's the principle
that i live by
in this case
and then you can apply it however you'd
like okay
the principle is that you are a good mom
you love your child
and you will be taking care of your
child that's correct isn't it
yes
okay
and since you're a good mom and you love
your child and you will be taking care
of your child
you are your child's best
funding mechanism
and so when you pay off your debt it
makes you more able to take care of your
child
so given that you're a good mom and
you're going to take care of your child
paying off your debt with it is not a
selfish thing to do it isn't like you
stole it from your kid or something like
that now if you took the money and went
and bought cocaine with it because
you're not a good mom
then that'd be different right
right but given that you're a good mom
and the fact that you get out of debt
makes you more able to take care of your
child
in that case if you got a 50 000 check
and it made you debt-free i would still
tell you to pay off the debt
okay because you're going to use the
fact that you're free to build wealth
and take better care of your child so
your child benefits either way
so the the premise you know somehow and
somehow in our minds the premises it
feels like we stole it from our kid or
something
you know what i'm saying
and that's just not my point is that's
not an accurate premise that's not an
accurate view on how this is going to go
down and so ken i'll give you another
example um
child support
okay
child support coming from a spouse
well it needs to be spent on the child
no it doesn't
no it doesn't because child support is
never enough to take care of a child
you never get enough child support to
support the child ever
so you're always going to spend more
than the child support
check coming in on the child
so just dump the child support check
into your budget
because the net effect is you will have
spent it on your kid anyway yeah but
this idea that somehow you have to
segment it off to the side or you've
been immoral and stolen money from your
kid is something that runs through our
heads yeah it's true it's a false
narrative exactly
do what's best with the money and that's
best for the child and you're gonna end
up having done more for the kid than
this money anyway by far
by far you're gonna spend more than
three thousand dollars on this kit by
far you're going to spend more than
um
so it's just a
it is a false narrative that the money
must be set to the side in the child's
name somehow or we've done something
wrong and we get that i guess from
watching something like some hollywood
child actors parents
takes advantage of them
or something like that and that's where
we get this concept from in our head
where we see parents that have
misbehaved but in 99 of the cases the
money coming into your house for your
kid is less than enough to take care of
your kid so you're going to spend more
than that on them anyway
which means you there was no transfer
here there was no
you know no no problem in the in the
ethics of the situation
uh jamie's with us jamie's in sacramento
hi jamie how are you
hey dave it's an honor to speak with you
and ken today i'm a big fan thanks
what's up
well real quick i recently turned 23 i'm
a graduate from ucla uh and i'm blessed
enough to say that i got my dream job um
earlier you know in the year i'm a
financial advisor and you know the
company
paid for my licensing everything got
taken care of the whole shopping so
i'm very very blessed but one problem
that i've run into already some of the
hurdles from my career that i've run
into in my business is that
you know because of my age and lack of
life experience
you know i it's just kind of tough you
know getting started and i talk with
clients much older than me and you know
i'm over here teaching them how to
manage um you know money and wealth and
you know it's just been a little bit
tough in that respect do you have any
any tips or advice you give me i know
you started real estate at a young age
different fields but be more be more
specific it sounds like you've
encountered some hurdles some challenges
is this fact feeling
be specific about how this is playing
out because of your youth
right so let's just say i'm prospecting
right and you know i'm talking with um
you know somebody that i admire or
that's a previous
uh you know uh person that i that i you
know whether it be friends or family or
a business associate they're a little
older than me you know 40s 50s i run
into a couple of these situations where
i talk with them and tell them a little
bit about what i do
love to sit down and they're obviously
interested but i can tell from the way
they approach the conversation that
because of my age and and maybe my lack
of life experience you know are there
strangers or people that knew you when
you were a kid
uh both both i run into the problem but
mostly actually come to think of it
mostly people that i that i've known
this far my natural market around me but
yeah that's why they still see you as
young jamie they have a past experience
um i you know look i'll i'll tell you i
got involved in politics very early in a
previous life and i was i was 22 working
for the governor of virginia and i
encountered some of this and if i look
back on it now i wish i would have been
able to advise myself
i think there's two dynamics with the
people that know you that's part of the
issue for strangers
i would take the elephant out of the
room and what i mean by that you
probably know what that phrase means so
i'm an old guy so i would address what
you think might be a hurdle but don't
don't dwell on it i would just say hey i
know i'm a young guy
but i've trained here this year this
year this year here's our strategy
here's our philosophy it worked for this
firm and we've you know i would lead
always with the strategy the training
you have the
quality around you the support all of
that so they're not hiring a 23 year old
uh they're hiring a strategy and a
reputable firm maybe a philosophy you
know you listen to dave ramsey find out
if they're ramsey people if it's a
positive thing i'd lead with that uh but
address the fact that even though you're
young and then drive right by it but
address the fact that you know you're
young but it doesn't have any relevance
to your ability to serve them yeah um
you know one things i would do you know
i was 18 19 years old selling a house um
i would go
you know
obviously i'm not 50 years old but i did
sell 42 houses last year that's exactly
the example that's perfect you know and
so i i'm seem to be doing a lot of it
right and it you know if you want that
kind of thing i can do that kind of
thing for you now you know
if you just want old people i can't help
you because i ain't old people yeah but
i didn't sell 42 houses last year so
what do you want to do and uh i know
what i'm doing that's beautiful right
there because you took care of their
objections exactly and the only question
i've got as an old guy is if the 23 year
old can do his stuff
right that's the only thing i care about
yeah i know i know he can fix my iphone
but can he you know does he know
anything else i mean you know that's the
only thing i want to know
and if you prove to me you know your
stuff i don't really care how old you
are
i don't really care whether you're a man
or a woman i don't really care what
color you are all i care is can you do
your stuff that's all i care
uh and that's that's what people most
people are that way really by the way so
but you're gonna have the most trouble
with old family and friends because it
is really hard once they change your
diaper in the uh sunday in the uh baby
baby nursery at the church you're gonna
struggle
this is the ramsey show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christchurch associate producer
and phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you